[Music]
bill Potter you're my best friend in a
world we must defend
we've both been playing Pokemon let's go
Pikachu / Evie they obviously take some
elements of Pokemon go and add them into
a slightly mainline Pokemon mix but tell
me how you think gameplay wise they
compare to the proper Pokemon games that
people can already get obviously the
biggest difference is the capture
mechanic that has completely changed so
Pokemon are no longer random encounters
you see Pokemon in the world which I do
like I mean I think the game challenges
two parts of acknowledged Pokemon Canon
one is that in the anime ash would see
Pokemon in the grass so that's kind of
cool that you see the Pokemon in the
wild and that helps make the world feel
more alive now there are wild Pokemon
roaming around which is quite nice adds
a new flavor to Pokemon that you've not
really had before on the flipside you no
longer battle wild Pokemon which goes
against every single Pokemon anime and
game so far from Pokemon go apart from
Pokemon go in some ways it works and in
a lot of ways it doesn't III think it's
a lot easier to catch pokemon now and a
lot quicker so you can be collecting way
more Pokemon instead of having to battle
them and get their HP down low and apply
status effects and all of that sort of
thing however it is completely dependent
on motion controls almost anyways yeah
unless you're playing in handheld mode
right in which case you can just press a
but even then you've still got motion
controls on so you're like if you're on
the train or ever you're sort of like
shaking around yeah it's a bit it's not
perfectly intuitive I don't think is it
it's not I've mainly been playing docked
on my TV right because to me I've always
wanted a main Pokemon game on my TV with
great graphics and it has that however
it does force you to either flick your
joy Kon forward or use the pokeball Plus
accessory we prepared yeah
however it's not as accurate as it
should be
if the Pokemon is dead in front of you
it's fine and it's quite easy to get
those balls right WeChat inform your
child if the Pokemon is dead in front of
you it's quite easy to just chuck the
ball and get it on target and it has
different levels so it's like the
smaller the circle just like an Pokemon
go the better the chance of catching
that Pokemon however some of the Pokemon
move from left to right up and down and
I'll be flying there might be dodging
and then to me the game just completely
breaks because I'd be trying to throw a
ball in one direction and then it goes
in another and it was infuriating I was
trying to catch a Clefairy
and it just was not happening but in
handheld it's a bit better unless you're
on the tube or on the bus yeah but how
have you found that so far if you've
been paying mainly in handheld or dock
I've mainly been playing handheld yeah
and and it's I mean I'm still a little
earlier on than you so I haven't found
it so bad so far because I haven't come
across higher-level Pokemon that I'm
moving around more I think the
interesting thing about let's go is that
it symbolizes to me an attempt by the
Pokemon company to try and unify the
Pokemon universe you know they've been
saying for a while how they've been
trying to make the art so in the games
more like what it is in the anime and
like you were talking about with seeing
the Pokemon in the overworld I think it
all makes it feel like you said a much
more real world and they've obviously
now brought in elements from Pokemon go
which is which was until this point a
completely different series to the
mainline series they've brought that
into a mainline type game with let's go
you know it's commendable that they're
trying to do that and make it easier for
players who aren't perhaps as
experienced with the main series to get
on board but yeah like you said I don't
think it's a move that's been a hundred
percent successful I think to me I would
much rather it was the standard battling
system the standard catching system the
motion controls aren't perfect you can
just about look past them at least at
the stage I'm at but it's the fact
you have to look past them in order to
enjoy it rather than enjoying it more
because of them you know I mean and I
think the main problem with with that
whole thing for me is that it's made the
game way too easy like the Pokemon games
have been getting easier for the last
few years anyway and now it's just it's
so easy the battles amount to nothing
more than just pressing area over and
over for me
no and it's worth reiterating that when
you do get into a battle at least in a
trainer battle the mechanics are much
the same as in any previous mainline
Pokemon game
[Music]
I'm really enjoying let's go people to
because of the music and the the sights
and the Nostalgia effects like obviously
this is red and blue that we're talking
about essentially it's a remake and it's
amazing and this was the Pokemon game
that I always dreamed of as a kid except
for the fact that it's just so easy now
and it takes away some of that
satisfaction I think yeah I think I
think it does make up in its charm like
having a companion either peek true or
Eevee who have full sort of like voice
acting they make the noises from the
anime you can it has the sort of
pokémon-amie style interaction with your
main Pokemon yeah and you can they sort
of interact with you talk to them they
react to you they give you presents you
can dress them up and then you can have
Pokemon following you you can ride
Pokemon in the world that to me is
something I've always dreamt of in
Pokemon games and it's been done in in
different ways over previous games but
this feels like it's finally like it's
realized in just the right way to make
it feel like a a perfect visit to your
childhood and what Pokemon was to us
back then it feels like it's now the
modern version of that and I think for
anyone who's picking this up now and who
had paid the originals like we did it's
just like such a joy to play and it's
it's it is easy but at the same time I'm
finding it very relaxing I'm coming off
games like Red Dead Redemption and God
of War and spider-man which are quite
serious and then I'm playing Pokemon and
it's just nice and fun and wholesome and
I just enjoy being in that world
[Music]
so Pokemon let's go is a combination of
previous Pokemon games and Pokemon go do
you think this is going to appeal to
people who have been playing the
mainline series of Pokemon games yeah I
think so I think definitely if you've
been playing the series for a while
you'll have that nostalgia because
there's a good chance if you're a
Pokemon fan you've I either played red
or blue or yellow or fire red or leaf
green and so you'll have that nostalgia
here it doesn't really I think develop
the series in the same way that a proper
new generation would have because it is
essentially a remake with elements of
Pokemon go add it in but at the end of
the day it's a good Pokemon game well
it's a Pokemon game therefore it's good
it's a good Pokemon game on the Nintendo
switch it looks amazing it sounds
amazing
it might not be perfect I would much
rather have had the battle mechanics the
same as in the mainline series but I
think at the end of the day is it's it's
a very good video game and I think
anyone who's into Pokemon will get a
good amount of enjoyment out of let's go
yeah everything I'm enjoying about this
game isn't necessarily the gameplay
which like you say maybe would have
preferred a more traditional game it's
not the next step from Sun and Moon
it feels like it's revisiting red blue
yellow those traditional games and if
you braid those this is going to feel
very very similar
[Music]
I think the interesting thing is that
they've obviously added in the the
caching mechanic to be very similar to
go and other smaller elements from go
like CP for example and that's obviously
an attempt to try and they've said this
that it's an attempt to try and get
people who played Pokemon go into the
mainline series but I think it arrives a
bit too late to really catch that hype
you know Pokemon go was really super
popular maybe two years ago now I think
the only people left playing Pokemon go
now by and large are Pokemon fans so
they were already gonna buy this whereas
I think they've angled it at people who
only play Pokemon go like all my friends
who played Pokemon go because everyone
was playing it but didn't weren't really
into Pokemon they've stopped playing
pokemon go ages ago by now and they
don't have nintendo switches so they're
definitely not gonna buy let's go yeah I
think that's the interesting thing
they've compromised I think where fans
would have really liked to have seen
this game go to appeal to a more sort of
wide audience and I don't think that
audience is there anymore really there's
definitely a big gap between a free app
on your phone and everyone has a phone
to an expensive console and a game yeah
so I I'm interested to see how many
people who played red and blue and the
other played go I'm interested to see
how many of those people have gone on to
the switch I'd love to see lots of
people doing that because I think it's
the perfect stepping stone and this must
have been the strategy for when the next
main Pokemon game comes out on the
switch there's a fan base they're ready
and waiting for the next Pokemon game
and then they can take Sun and Moon and
think how are we gonna develop this into
the next main Pokemon series hmm it
probably won't use a lot from let's go
in fact I hope it doesn't
I love let's go and I'm really enjoying
it but I think it's it's only thing
maybe they'll do future spin-offs maybe
they'll do gold and silver go to joto
with those mechanics but I'd love to see
them maybe take a similar look and feel
and develop that into the next main
switch game Pokemon fans are probably
going to play this regardless if they've
been playing all of the DS the 3ds games
they're still going to enjoy this but it
gonna be not a lot of new mainly a and
mass Tyler trip alright guys that was
our thoughts on Pokemon let's go Pikachu
/e v and how it compares to previous
games in the series let us know your
thoughts on let's go in the comment
section below or you can find us on
Twitter I'm at dare says I'm at the
Clippers dead thanks for watching guys
we'll see you next time
[Music]